I always have this feeling of no I need
in the war I need to know more you have
to shake off this notion that you will
just be a manager and your team will
take care of everything for you you need
to know the details of your business
certain things like learning how to
learn like meta learning or improving
your memory improves everything
[Music]
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation eight seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message learn more over
to you Dan Locke when at the first
business pilot that I had it was like a
basically he was my neighbor at a time I
was trying to build my little business
and he sold me on the concept oh you
need a website and I pay him some money
a long story short he's basically scared
me out of like hundred fifty thousand
dollars I lost all my mom's money all
the savings and I didn't know anything
about into the marketing and then right
after that because that experience was
so traumatic for me from then on
everything I do I said I want to learn
in a hundred percent so I went and at a
time internet marketing
I bought the corey rudl course and
remember the insider secrets to mocking
the internet right that the two big
binders like 600 pages I went through in
two days Wow and from then on I was just
like reading every I forget about like
reading a book a month I was reading a
book every two three days so that
experience change how I operate and that
that's hard evolve this hunger to learn
yeah as much as I could so I would feel
I don't think it's a healthy thing is
when I went to Tony's event unleash the
power within yeah I don't know there's
there's a healthy thing but I always
have this feeling of no I need to know
more right I need to know more if you
don't know your business you're done you
can't just be a manager you can't just
hire people expect them to do everything
with you having a limited knowledge
about the business that you are in the
most successful entrepreneurs know an
insane amount about the details that go
into making their product or service
come alive because they did it likely
themselves from scratch they started up
they were one woman one-man show and
built it from there but too many people
want to just be managers want to think
like I'm just gonna hire teamm and
they'll take care of everything meat for
me and I'm just gonna lie on a beach
that's not how it works if you want to
be an effective manager you have to
understand the process and the details
that go into all of the work that has to
get done it doesn't mean you have to be
the best and the expert at everything
but you have to have an understanding
you have to shake off this notion that
you will just be a manager and your team
will take care of everything for you you
need to know the details of your
business ok so how do you do it what are
the steps I'm gonna give you three tips
that I think will really help you number
one I had to start do everything I'm a
big fan of doing everything myself when
I started this YouTube channel I already
had built and sold a successful business
I already was running a second
successful business and this was a
side-project hobby for me I love getting
my hands dirty on new things and doing
everything myself at the start just so I
get a grasp and an understanding of
what's happening so when I did my first
YouTube videos they're pretty bad but I
did everything I filmed them I did them
I researched them I was in front of the
camera behind the camera working on the
titles working on the thumbnails
everything I did everything everything
everything everything everything
everything for every video was me now I
quickly learned what went into making a
youtube video it was a really slow
process with me doing everything because
I wasn't very good at any of this stuff
and I realized that something like
editing was something that I didn't want
to do I understood the process but I'd
rather hire a much better editor than me
to help speed that process up but I'm a
big fan at the beginning of doing
everything myself I think you need to
get your hands dirty I think you would
need to have an understanding of how
your business works and yes that slows
things down but raising capital or
taking out a big loan and then hiring a
bunch of people who you don't know what
they're working on and
they can out talk to you and outsmart
you and all the things that they're in
you have zero clue what's happening is a
recipe for disaster
start at the beginning by doing
everything yourself don't spend any
money until you're making money and
build up from there
number two is know enough to be
dangerous if you want to be an effective
manager you have to know enough to be
dangerous you have to know enough about
all the pieces of the business to be
dangerous and so looking at this YouTube
business for an example there's there's
we're growing I keep seeing eight people
but but we're probably like up to
sixteen or something now lots of
different people involved in making
these YouTube videos I am best at being
in front of the camera and then
filtering believe so every video has to
have believe 'not and I've done I think
a good job in bringing on people who
understand my vision and they help find
the clips and they help do the editing
and they surround my in abilities my
weaknesses but that's what I do best
being in front of the camera coming up
with creative ideas number two and then
being the belief filter now I couldn't
come in and do a better job than a lot
of the people who are on my team
Christina does a lot of the editing I
Christina Christina and her husband Sam
do the editing for my videos I could not
come in and edit videos like they do I
could not come in and do the thumbnails
like they do I could not come in and do
the research like Ivan does I could not
come in and do a lot of the work that my
team does I know enough about everything
to be dangerous that not only if any of
them left that I'd have to jump in and
do it myself but I can understand what
their job function is and I can help
give guidance to help more importantly
come up with new ideas of what we should
be doing because I have a general
understanding I'm not the best but I
know enough to be dangerous and I think
that is a healthy mindset to take into
your business you don't want to be the
best at everything in your business that
is also a recipe for disaster you should
not be the best you should hire people
who are better than you at the things
that you are not Michael Jordan level
talent act you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something you want to spend as
much time as you can in that zone right
now maybe it's only 5% of your time and
you want to move to 20 and so to do that
you have to hire people and ideally
you're hiring the Michael Jordan's of
what they do but
think you should know enough just enough
to be dangerous at every function in the
business so that you can push them so
you can be creative so that you can be a
visionary there and so you can improve
the overall product and service that you
were putting out if you do not know
enough to be dangerous in every role in
your business it's a liability and
you're likely to lose and number three
is being gauged you have to be engaged
in every department it's not enough to
just know enough to be dangerous about
it you have to be actively engaged you
have to be monitoring you have to be not
from a Big Brother like looking at your
computer and making sure you're doing
work I hate that micromanagement but
being involved being creative having a
presence knowing that what they do is
important it's so funny since since I
started getting on Instagram so many
people DM me I get I get DMS every day
from people to say hey we can automate
your entire process you know we can come
up with the pictures and we can do the
captions and we can respond the people
on DM you don't have to do anything you
don't have to lift a finger it's
ridiculous whoever signs up for that
package is going to lose you need to be
engaged you need to have your fingers on
the content you don't have to be the one
pressed ain't post on everything the
thing that goes up but you need to be
there your presence your voice your soul
has to be in every part of the company
and I get that you want to hire people
because you can go a lot further when
you have a team and I absolutely agree
and I love my team and they're so
insanely helpful but I am engaged I'm
engaged with everybody on my team I
understand their job function I'm
meeting with them regularly I'm thinking
about ways not just to make their life
better and help them accomplish their
goals even if it means leaving my
company but their job function the work
that they're working on how do I make it
more interesting how do I bring more
value to it so that they get more
interest out of it but also you guys
benefit more my customers my audience
benefit from it more as well if you are
looking at some automated way to win you
are gonna lose you have to learn as an
entrepreneur to love being engaged and I
love hacks and I love I love being on
top of new software and new tools and
we're doing things that haven't been
done before on YouTube and on Instagram
I love shortcuts I love I love I love I
love shortcuts which
I'll have a mountain to climb and you
better love climbing that mountain stop
thinking that everything can be
automated and be engaged now I've got a
really special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for question of the day I want to
know what is one area in your business
that you need to be more engaged in let
me know put it down in the comments
below
I think that if there's one skill to
master in the 21st century it's the
ability to learn rapidly it's if you
know what it is they call it in the
military a forced multiplier mmm-hmm a
force multiplier is like an input goes
in but you get exponential output from
it
it's like optimism being positive as it
forced multipliers right you know in :
Paulo said that and so certain things
like learning how to learn like meta
learning or improving your memory
improves everything improves your
business improves like you know you
could remember people's names you can
remember sales presentations you could
remember things about of people cuz like
for example it's hard to show somebody
for people were watching this they're
entrepreneurs right and they're wearing
business development hat you know it's
really hard to show someone you're gonna
care for their business their future
their family their health or fitness
whatever you're selling them if you
don't care enough just to remember
things like their name or name you know
or somewhere that or their or their kids
name or their birthdays you know so
that's a memory is a multiplier they are
a memories a multiplier in their
relationships
you know like relationships just
remembering those those moments you know
like you know not even just a memory
anniversaries remembering to take out
the garbage that kinda stuff but
remembering you know the first time you
and your loved one you know took that
walk on that beach you know what I mean
those kind of moments that make
everything worthwhile yeah but it's it's
wonderful for every area of some every
day I do believe that tomb of the most
costly words and business for example or
I forgot you know I forgot to do it I
forgot to bring it I forgot any name I
forgot your name it's the words like
could you get forgetting someone's name
and I've seen this time and time again
they could hurt a relationship it could
kill deals I've had people call someone
by the wrong name and they've lost
multiple million dollar deals just on
that one of the things that companies do
or startups do they come up with an idea
they'll Google it and if they don't see
it in the first two pages they think
it's original you've got to go back
right because over the past 15 years
there's so many different businesses
that have tried and failed you have to
go back and find those and learn from
those so you've got to understand all
the implications and you have to learn
from history and so the best advice I
can give you on a video before talking
to you or emailing with you is that
you've got to find out the history of
people who have tried your idea because
there's a 99.99999% chance
that your idea has been tried before
that's not a good reason not to start it
because you might be able to outperform
them but you better learn from the
history of your idea um because you know
what they say about people who don't
learn from history is that wisdom
acquisition was a moral duty it's not
something you do just to advance in life
wisdom acquisition is a moral duty and
as a corollary to that proposition which
is very important it means that you're
hooked for life time learning and
without lifetime learning you people are
not gonna do very well you are not going
to get ready for our life based on what
you already know you're going to advance
in life by what you're going to learn
after you leave here if you take
Berkshire Hathaway which is certainly
one of the best regarded corporations in
the world and may have the best invest
long-term investment record in the
entire history of civilization the skill
that got Berkshire through one decade
would not have suffice to get it through
the next decade with the achievements
made without Warren Buffett being a
learning machine continuous learning
machine the record would have been
absolutely impossible the same is true
at lower walks of life I constantly see
people rise in life
we're not the smartest sometimes not
even the most diligent but they are
learning machines they go to bed every
night a little wiser than they were when
they got up and boy does that habit help
particularly when you have a long run
ahead of you hi this is Dan Locke if
you're a fan of Evans work if you want
to know exactly how the model my success
I want to invite you to join me for a
special online training all you have to
do is click on a link below you can join
me for absolutely no charge so click a
link below and I will see you in class
if you want more dan lock check at the
top ten rules video I did on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there getting rich is not
an act it is a habit so it is staying
poor it's also a habit